this lesson is adapted from an article
by gabriela veneziano who's one of the
founders of string theory and one of the
first to apply string theory to black
holes and cosmology
was the big bang really the beginning of
time
or did the universe exist before then
such a question seemed almost
blasphemous only decades ago most
cosmologists insisted that it made no
sense that to contemplate a time before
the big bang was like asking for
directions to a place north of the north
pole
but developments in theoretical physics
especially the rise of string theory
have changed their perspective
the pre-bang universe has actually
become a frontier of cosmology
and the new willingness to consider what
might have happened before the big bang
is the latest swing of an intellectual
pendulum that's been rocking back and
forth for millennia
in one form or another the issue of the
ultimate beginning has engaged
philosophers and theologians in nearly
every culture it's entwined with a grand
set of concerns one famously
encapsulated in an 1897 painting by paul
gagan titled
where do we come from what are we
where are we going
the peace depicts the cycle of birth
life and death the origin identity and
destiny for each individual and these
personal concerns connect directly to
cosmic ones
we can trace our own lineage back
through the generations
in fact now scientists can trace our
lineage through the first land animal
ancestors to early forms of life to
proto-life to the elements that were
synthesized in the primordial universe
to the amorphous energy deposited in
space even before that
does our family tree extend forever
backward or do its roots terminate
is the cosmos as impermanent as we are
the ancient greeks debated the origin of
time fiercely
taking the no beginning side aristotle
invoked the principle that out of
nothing nothing comes
if the universe could never have gone
from nothingness to somethingness
it must always have existed
for this and other reasons time must
stretch eternally into the past and into
the future
christian theologians tended to take the
opposite point of view
augustine contended that god exists
outside of space and time able to bring
these constructs into existence as
surely as he would forge other aspects
of our world
when asked what was god doing before he
created the world augustine answered
since time itself is part of god's
creation there was simply no before
einstein's general theory of relativity
led modern cosmologists to much the same
conclusion
the theory holds that space and time are
malleable
on the largest scales space is naturally
dynamic expanding or contracting over
time carrying matter like driftwood on
the tide
in the 1920s astronomers confirmed that
our universe is expanding
distant galaxies move apart from one
another
one consequence of this as physicists
stephen hawking and roger penrose proved
in the 1960s is that time cannot extend
back indefinitely
as you play cosmic history backward in
time
the galaxies all come together into a
single infinitesimal point known as a
singularity
almost as if they were descending into a
black hole
each galaxy or its precursor is squeezed
down to zero size
quantities such as density temperature
space-time curvature all become infinite
the singularity is the ultimate
cataclysm beyond which our cosmic
ancestry cannot extend
the unavoidable singularity poses
serious problems for cosmologists
for the cosmos to look broadly the same
everywhere as it does
some kind of communication had to pass
among distant regions of space
somehow coordinating their properties
yet the idea of such communication
contradicts our standard understanding
of cosmology
so consider what's happened over the
past 13.8 billion years since the big
bang
the distance between galaxies has grown
by a factor of about a thousand because
the universe is expanding
while the radius of the observable
universe has grown even more by the
factor of about a hundred thousand and
that's because light is even faster than
the expansion of the universe
so today we see parts of the universe
that we could not have seen 13.8 billion
years ago
indeed this is the first time in cosmic
history that light from the most distant
galaxies has reached us in the milky way
nevertheless the properties of our milky
way galaxy are basically the same as
those of all the distant galaxies
it's like showing up at a party only to
find you're wearing exactly the same
outfit as a dozen of your friends
if just two of you were dressed the same
it might be explained away as a
coincidence but it doesn't suggest that
everyone coordinated their attire in
advance
in cosmology it's not clothes but
independent yet statistically identical
patches of sky in what's called the
cosmic microwave background radiation
which is the afterglow from the big bang
and the number isn't just a dozen but
rather tens of thousands
so one possible explanation is that all
those regions of space were endowed at
birth with identical properties in other
words that the homogeneity is is just a
coincidence
however
physicists have come up with two other
more natural ways out of this impasse
one is that the early universe was
either much smaller or much older than
is known from standard cosmology
either or actually both they could act
together would have made
intercommunication possible
so one explanation follows the first
alternative it postulates that the
universe went through a period of
accelerating expansion known as
inflation early in its history
before this phase
galaxies or their precursors were so
closely packed that they could easily
coordinate their properties
and then during inflation they fell out
of contact because light couldn't keep
pace with the frenetic expansion
after inflation ended the expansion
began to decelerate so galaxies
gradually came back into one another's
view
physicists ascribe the inflationary
spurt to the potential energy stored in
a new quantum field which is called the
inflaton which happened about 10 to the
negative 35 second after the big bang
unlike mass or kinetic energy potential
energy leads to gravitational repulsion
so rather than slowing down the
expansion as gravitation of ordinary
matter wood the inflaton accelerated it
proposed in 1981 inflation has explained
a wide variety of observations with
precision
but a number of possible theoretical
problems remain beginning with the
questions of what exactly the inflaton
was and what gave it such huge initial
potential energy
so that's inflation
but another way to solve the puzzle
follows the second alternative by just
getting rid of the singularity
if time didn't begin at the big bang and
if a long era preceded the onset of the
present cosmic expansion the matter
could have had plenty of time to arrange
itself smoothly and this has led some
researchers to re-examine the reasoning
that led them to infer a singularity in
the first place
so one of the assumptions
that relativity theory is always valid
is questionable
uh close to the putative singularity
quantum effects must have been important
or even dominant
standard relativity takes no account of
such effects so accepting the
inevitability of the singularity amounts
to trusting the theory really beyond
reason
so to know what really happened
physicists need to include relativity in
a quantum theory of gravity
this task has occupied theorists from
albert einstein onward but progress was
almost zero until the
mid-1980s today two approaches stand out
one is called loop quantum gravity and
it retains einstein's theory essentially
intact but it changes the procedure for
implementing it in quantum mechanics
so practitioners of loop quantum gravity
have taken great strides and achieved
deep insights over the past several
years
still their approach may not be enough
to resolve the fundamental problems of
quantizing gravity
so a second approach is string theory
and that is a really revolutionary
modification of einstein's theory
and this is what we'll focus on here
although proponents of loop quantum
gravity reach some of the same
conclusions
so string theory grew out of a model
that physicist gabriella veneziano wrote
in 1968 to describe the world of nuclear
particles which are you know protons and
neutrons in their interactions
so despite a lot of initial excitement
the model was abandoned several years
later in favor of another model called
quantum chromodynamics which describes
nuclear particles in terms of more
elementary constituents called quarks
quarks are confined inside a proton or
neutron as if they were tied together by
elastic strings
in retrospect the original string theory
had captured these stringy aspects of
the nuclear world
only later it was revived as a candidate
for combining general relativity and
quantum theory
so the basic idea is that elementary
particles are not point-like but rather
infinitely thin one-dimensional objects
and these are the strings so the zoo we
know of elementary particles each of
which has its own characteristic
properties
those reflect the many possible
vibration patterns of a string
so
how can such a simple-minded theory
which is what veneziano calls it how can
that describe the complicated world of
particles in all their interactions
and so the answer can be found in what
he dubbed quantum string magic
once the rules of quantum mechanics are
applied to a vibrating string
just like a miniature violin string
except that the vibrations propagate
along it at the speed of light
once that happens new properties appear
and all of these have profound
implications for particle physics and
for cosmology so the smallest and the
biggest
first quantum strings have a finite size
if it weren't for quantum effects a
violin string could be cut in half
cut in half again and so on all the way
down finally becoming a massless
point-like particle
but heisenberg's uncertainty principle
eventually intrudes if you get small
enough and that prevents even the
lightest strings from being sliced
smaller than about 10 to the negative
34th meter
this irreducible quantum of length which
is denoted as l sub s
is a new constant of nature introduced
by string theory
it plays a crucial role in almost every
aspect of string theory and it puts a
finite limit on quantities that
otherwise could become either zero or
infinite
so second quantum strings may have
angular momentum even if they lack mass
now in classical physics angular
momentum is a property of an object that
rotates with respect to an axis
so the formula for angular momentum
multiplies together velocity mass and
distance from the axis so hence a
massless object can't have angular
momentum
but quantum fluctuations change the
situation
a tiny string can acquire a certain
amount of angular momentum even without
having any mass
so this feature precisely matches the
properties of all the fundamental forces
such as the photon which is for
electromagnetism and the graviton for
gravity
historically angular momentum is what
clued physicists into the quantum
gravitational implications of string
theory
so third
quantum strings demand the existence of
extra dimensions of space
whereas a classical violin string will
vibrate no matter what the properties of
space and time are a quantum string is
more finicky
the equations describing the vibration
become inconsistent unless space-time is
either highly curved
which is contrary to what we observe or
if it contains six additional spatial
dimensions
fourth
physical constants no longer have
arbitrary fixed values instead they
occur in string fury as fields rather
like the electromagnetic field that can
adjust their values dynamically
so these fields may have taken different
values in different cosmological epochs
or in remote regions of space
and even today the physical constants
that we know may vary by a small amount
and observing any variation would
provide an enormous boost to string
theory
one of the fields called the dilaton is
the master key to string theory
it determines the overall strength of
all interactions
the diletton fascinates string theorists
because its value can be reinterpreted
as the size of an extra dimension of
space giving a grand total of 11
space-time dimensions
so finally quantum strings have
introduced physicists to some striking
new symmetries of nature known as
dualities
which alter our intuition for what
happens when objects get extremely small
typically a short string is lighter than
a long one but if we attempt to squeeze
down its size below the fundamental
length of l sub s
then the string gets heavier again
so another form of symmetry is called t
duality and it holds that small and
large extra dimensions are equivalent
and this symmetry arises because strings
can move in more complicated ways than
point-like particles can
[Music]
so consider a closed string which is a
loop
located on a cylindrically shaped space
whose circular cross section represents
one finite extra dimension
so besides vibrating the string can
either turn as a hole around the
cylinder or wind around it one or
several times like a rubber band wrapped
up around a rolled up poster
so the energetic cost of these two
states of the string depend on the size
of the cylinder
the energy of winding is directly
proportional to the cylinder radius
larger cylinders require the string to
stretch more as it wraps around
and the winding contains more energy
than they would on a smaller cylinder
the energy associated with moving around
the circle on the other hand is
inversely proportional to the radius
larger cylinders allow for longer
wavelengths which have smaller
frequencies and that represents less
energy than shorter wavelengths do
so if a large cylinder is substituted
for a small one the two states of motion
can swap roles
energies that have been produced by
circular motion are instead produced by
winding and vice versa
an outside observer notices only the
energy levels not the origin of those
levels
so to the observer the large and small
radii are physically equivalent
so although this t duality is usually
described in terms of cylindrical spaces
uh where one dimension is finite
a variant of it applies also to our
ordinary three dimensions which appear
to stretch on indefinitely
but we have to be careful when talking
about the expansion of an infinite space
its overall size can't change it remains
infinite but it can still expand in the
sense that bodies embedded within it
such as galaxies can keep moving apart
from one another
so the crucial variable is not the size
of the space as a whole but what's
called its scale factor and the scale
factor is the distance
describes how the distance between
galaxies changes
now according to t duality universes
with small scale factors are equivalent
to ones with large scale factors
but no such symmetry is present in
einstein's equations it emerges from the
unification that string theory embodies
with the dilaton playing a central role
for years string theorists thought that
t duality applied only to closed strings
as opposed to open strings which have
loose ends and thus can't wind
but in the 1990s scientists realized
that t duality did apply to open strings
provided the switch between the large
and small radii was accompanied by a
change in the conditions at the
endpoints of the string
and certain boundary conditions describe
how those ends stay put
for instance electrons may be strings
whose ends can move around freely in
three of the ten spatial dimensions that
are stuck within the other seven
those three dimensions form a subspace
known as a dirac chalet membrane or a d
brain
in 1996 peter harava of the university
of california at berkeley and edward
whitton of the institute for advanced
study in princeton new jersey proposed
that our universe resides on such a
brain
[Music]
the partial mobility of electrons and
other particles explains why we are
unable to perceive the full
10-dimensional glory of space
all of the magic properties of quantum
strings point in one direction
strings abhor infinity they can't
collapse to an infinitesimal point
so they avoid the paradoxes that
collapse in tails
their non-zero size and their novel
symmetries set upper bounds to the
physical quantities that increase
without limit in conventional theories
and they set lower bounds to quantities
that decrease
string theorists expect that when you
play the history of the universe
backward in time the curvature of space
time starts to increase
but instead of going all the way back to
infinity which is the traditional big
bang singularity it eventually hits a
maximum and then shrinks again
before string theory physicists were
hard pressed to imagine any mechanism
that could so clearly eliminate the need
for a singularity
conditions near the zero time of the big
bang were so extreme that no one yet
knows how to solve the equations
nevertheless string theories have
hazarded guesses about the called the
pre-bang universe and two popular models
are still floating around
the first is known as the pre-big bang
scenario which gabriella veneziano and
his colleagues began to develop in 1991.
it combines t duality with the better
known symmetry of time reversal whereby
the equations of physics work equally
well when applied backward and forward
in time
the combination gives rise to new
possible cosmologies in which the
universe
say five seconds before the big bang
expanded at the same pace as it did five
seconds after the big bang
yet the rate of change of the expansion
was opposite at the two instances
if it was decelerating after the bang it
was accelerating before so in short the
big bang may not have been the origin of
the universe but instead simply a
violent transition from acceleration to
deceleration
so the beauty of this picture is that it
automatically incorporates the great
insight of standard inflationary theory
namely that the universe had to undergo
a period of acceleration to become so
homogeneous
in the standard theory acceleration
occurs after the big bang because of an
ad hoc in phleton field
in the pre-big bang scenario it happens
before the bang as a natural consequence
of the novel symmetries of string theory
so according to the scenario the
pre-bang universe was almost a perfect
mirror image of the post bang
if the universe is eternal into the
future it is also eternal into the past
infinitely long ago it was nearly empty
filled only with a tenuous widely
dispersed chaotic gas of radiation and
matter
the forces of nature controlled by the
diletton field were so feeble that
particles in this gas barely interacted
as time went on the forces gained in
strength and pulled matter together
randomly some regions accumulated matter
at the expense of their surroundings
and eventually the density in these
regions became so high that black holes
started to form
matter inside those regions was then cut
off from the outside
breaking the universe up into
disconnected pieces
inside a black hole space and time swap
rolls
the center of the black hole isn't a
point in space but an instant in time
as the in-falling matter approached the
center it reached higher and higher
densities
but when the density temperature and
curvature reached the maximum values
allowed by string theory these
quantities bounced and started
decreasing
the moment of that reversal called a big
bang was later renamed a big bounce
the interior one of these black holes
became our universe
not surprisingly
such an unconventional scenario has
provoked a lot of controversy
andre lind of stanford university has
argued that for this scenario to match
observations the black hole that gave
rise to our universe would have needed
to be unusually large
much larger than the length scale of
string theory
so an answer to this objection is that
the equations predict black holes of all
possible sizes
our universe just happened to form
inside a sufficiently large one
so a more serious objection argues that
it would that matter and space-time
would have behaved chaotically near the
moment of the bang impossible
contradiction with the observed
regularity of the early universe
gabriella veneziano has proposed that a
chaotic state would produce a dense gas
of miniature string holes
strings that were so small and massive
that they were on the verge of becoming
black holes
the second popular model for the
pre-bang universe is so-called
ecperotic or conflagration scenario
it relies on the idea that our universe
sits at one end of a higher dimensional
space
and a hidden brain sits at the opposite
end
the two brains exert an attractive force
on each other and occasionally collide
making the extra dimension shrink to
zero before growing again
the big bang would correspond to the
time of collision
so in a variant of this scenario the
collisions occurs cyclically
two brains might hit bounce off each
other move apart pull together again hit
again and so on
in between collisions the brains behave
like silly putty
expanding as they recede and contracting
somewhat as they come back together
during the turnaround
the expansion rate accelerates indeed
the present accelerating expansion of
our universe may auger another collision
so the pre-bang and eq-periodic
scenarios share some common features
both begin with a large cold nearly
empty universe
and both share the difficult problem of
making the transition between the pre
and the post bang phase
so mathematically the main difference
between the scenarios is the behavior is
of the diletton field
in the pre-bang the diletton begins with
a low value
so that forces of nature are weak and
then steadily gain strength
and the opposite is true for the ec
periodic scenario in which the collision
occurs when forces are at their weakest
the developers of the ecpirotic theory
initially hoped the weaknesses of forces
would allow the bounce to be analyzed
more easily but they were still
confronted with a difficult high
curvature situation
so the jury is still out on whether the
scenario truly avoids a singularity
so also the periodic scenario must
entail some very special conditions to
solve some of the usual cosmological
puzzles
so for instance the
brains when they're about to collide
must have been almost exactly parallel
to one another otherwise the collision
wouldn't have given rise to a
sufficiently homogeneous bang
the cyclic version may be able to take
care of this problem because successive
collisions would have allowed the brains
to straighten themselves
so leaving aside the difficult task of
fully justifying these two scenarios
mathematically physicists must also ask
whether they have any observable
physical consequences
for at first sight both scenarios might
seem like an exercise not in physics but
in metaphysics
interesting ideas that observers could
never prove either right or wrong
but a possible pre-banging epoch
could have observable consequences
especially for the very small variations
observed in the cosmic microwave
background temperature
so first
observations show that the temperature
fluctuations were shaped by acoustic
waves for several hundred thousand years
the regularity of the fluctuations
indicates that the waves were
synchronized
so cosmologists have discarded many
models over the years because they
failed to account for this synchrony
but the inflationary pre-big bang and
the equiotic scenarios all passed this
first test
in these models the waves were triggered
by quantum processes amplified during
the period of accelerating cosmic
expansion
the phases of these waves were aligned
so second each model predicts a
different distribution of the
temperature fluctuations with respect to
angular size
observers have found that fluctuations
of all sizes have approximately the same
amplitude
so discernible deviations occur only on
very small scales and for that
primordial fluctuations have been
altered by subsequent processes we don't
have to worry about that as much
inflationary models neatly reproduced
this distribution
during inflation the curvature of space
changed relatively slowly so
fluctuations of different sizes were
generated under much the same conditions
in both the stringy models the curvature
evolved quickly increasing the amplitude
of small-scale fluctuations but other
processes boosted the large-scale ones
leaving all fluctuations with the same
strength
for the ecperotic scenario those other
processes involved the extra dimension
of space the one that separated the
colliding brains
for the pre big bang scenario they
involved a quantum field called the
axion related to the diletton in short
all three models do match the data
variations in temperature can arise from
two distinct processes in the early
universe
fluctuations in the density of matter
and rippling caused by gravitational
waves
inflation involves both of these
processes whereas the pre-big bang and
periodic scenarios involve density
variations for the most part
gravitational waves of certain sizes
would leave a distinctive signature in
the polarization of the cosmic microwave
background radiation
so satellite and ground-based
observations may be able to see that
signature if it exists
and that would provide a really
definitive test
a fourth test
pertains to the statistics of the
fluctuations
in inflation the fluctuations follow a
bell-shaped curve and the same may be
true in the ek periodic case whereas the
pre-big bang scenario allows for a
sizeable deviation from such a curve
but analysis of the cosmic microwave
background radiation is not the only way
to verify these theories
the pre-big bang scenario should also
produce a random background of
gravitational waves in a range of
frequencies
that though they're irrelevant for the
microwave background should be
detectable by future gravitational wave
observatories
moreover because the pre big bang
universe and the eck periodic scenarios
involve changes in the diletton field
which is coupled to the electromagnetic
field they would both lead to large
scale magnetic field fluctuations
vestiges of these fluctuations might
show up in galactic and intergalactic
magnetic fields
so when did time begin
science doesn't have a conclusive answer
yet
but at least two potentially testable
theories plausibly hold that the
universe and therefore time existed well
before the big bang
if either scenario is right that means
the cosmos has always existed
and even if it collapses again one day
it always will exist
[Music]
you